they're targeting backyard archery in
Minnesota and massage shops in
California but this time we're heading
to the big skies state where one
lawmaker is cracking down on indecent
exposure and by indecent exposure we
mean of course yoga pants especially the
beige colored ones state representative
David Moore crafted a bill to expand
Montana's indecent exposure law warmest
bill would ban any device costume or
covering that gives the appearance of or
simulates the genitals pubic hair anus
region or pubic hair region or said his
bill could make tight-fitting beige aka
skin colored clothing illegal and hey
yoga pants should be illegal in public
anyway he says the bear is you dare
bicycle ride prompted more to fight back
against nakedness but before you go
broad brushing him keep in mind he's the
only Montana state Republican endorsed
by narrow and yes his bill would mandate
that male nipples also be shielded from
public fear Moore's bill was squashed in
committee and now he says he was just
kidding about the whole yoga pants ban
right because who would ever believe
that the guy who once said he wouldn't
have a problem with people being
arrested for wearing provocative
clothing would also want to outlaw yoga
pants or maybe the joke's on all of us
who just don't get representative
Moore's wry sense of humor the whole
thing was an off-the-cuff remark in the
hallway he said but The Associated Press
broke the story and they insist he
wasn't joking everyone from Jezebel to
Fox News mocked Moore's bill
so just maybe your name e the month
backtrack after feeling the heat
followed nanny the month on Twitter
submit your nanny nominees and check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies mind in your own business
you